[Music]
[Music]
house of the dragon a game of thrones
prequel show is coming in 2022 on hbo
and beside targaryens themselves
targaryen dragons will also play a major
role in this upcoming epic series
game of thrones had only 3 dragons and
it was a game changer
house of the dragon will feature over 20
dragons and even more epic dragon fights
dragons are the reason that the
dragonlord targaryen family frequently
married brother to sister to keep the
bloodline pure
as it generally believed that valyrian
heritage plays a part in bonding with a
dragon
provided it has a blood and freedom a
dragon never stops growing
the lifespan of dragons is many times
that of a human
although their maximum natural lifespan
is difficult to determine
as beasts of war most of the known
examples died in battle
valerian the largest and oldest
targaryen dragon already alive and house
targaryen relocated from valyria to
dragonstone in 114 bc
died of old age in 94 ac valerian was
near 200 years of age when he died
but as the only known example of a
dragon who died of old age
it's unclear if this should be
considered typical the valyrians had
thousands of dragons
after the doom of valyria however the
only dragons known to have survived
were five dragons on dragonstone they
belonged to house targaryen
who had brought them from valyria when
they went into exile
four of these dragons eventually died on
dragonstone
leaving only valerian however the other
dragons left eggs behind
and from these hatch to agar and mirxis
valerian called the black dread was
written by king aegon the first
targaryen
during his conquest valerian was the
largest and oldest targaryen dragon ever
his wingspan was so large that his
shadow could engulf
entire towns when he passed overhead his
teeth were as long as swords
and his jaws were large enough to
swallow a mammoth
beside by egg aegon the conqueror
valerian was also written by meg or the
cruel
princess saria targaryen and king wizard
is the first targaryen
valerian scales and wings were black his
fire was black as well
when he was in the fullness of his power
his flames could melt steel and stone
and fuse sand into a glass house
targaryen used valerian vegard and
marxists in their wars of conquest
against the seven kingdoms they were
instrumental in the burning of herron
hall and the field of fire
and the threat of dragons led to
submissions of torin stark
and shara rin dragons were also used in
the first dornish war
which caused the death of marxists at
the hellholt in 10 ac
she was ridden by queen reigning
targaryen and was named
for one of the gods of old valyria
marxist was larger than vegar
but smaller than valerian she could
swallow horses whole
marxists had golden eyes and silver
scales
while being ridden by queen rhaenys in
their invasion of dorne
an iron ball from a scorpion went
through marx's eye
and the dragon and rhaenys fell from the
sky to their deaths
many dragons were hatched after aegon's
conquest
during aegon's the first reign half a
dozen hatchlings are born on dragonstone
one of the first was quicksilver hatched
in 7ac
who bonded with aegon's the first elder
sun in air
aenes quarter the size of valerian her
fireballs were pale white in color
quicksilver died in 43ac in what became
the first time since the doom of valyria
that a dragonfall to dragon
in the battle beneath the god's eye
aegon the conqueror's grandson also
named aegon
attempted to win back the throne that by
rights was his
but both quick silver and aegon died
fighting maegor upon his dragon valerian
valerian grabbed quick silver's throat
in his jaws
then ripped one of quick silver's wings
from its body in mid-air
after which quicksilver fell to its
death along with young aegon
over the course of 150 years the
targaryens throw their dragons as a
symbol of their power
king jaherry is the first targaryen took
six dragons with him to winterfell
to visit the warden of the north this
included jaehaerys on vermethar
queen eliza on silverbank and four other
currently unknown dragons
birminthor called the bronze fury was a
male dragon
vermeethor was already a large dragon in
48 ac
only larger were valerian and bergar by
the time of the dance of the dragons
fermithar was almost 100 years old
valerian finally died of old age in 94
ac
late in the reign of joharis the first
jaehaerys's grandson and eventual
successor of theirs the first
was valerian's rider at the time of its
death this left vagar as the largest
living dragon
and by 129 ac she was approaching
ballerian
size by the end of the reign of king
viserys the first targaryen 20 dragons
were a line
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in ac and lasted until mid
131ac
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers
dragons fought the dragons by the time
it was over thousands were dead
the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population
ultimately leading to their extinction
within a few decades
they never truly recovered the largest
and the oldest dragons during the
targaryen civil war were regard
vermithor
silverbang dreamfire millies characters
and cyrex
the younger dragons still large enough
to be ridden to war where sea smoke
sunfire the syrian vermax iraq styraxis
and moondancer
stormcloud morgul and shrikhos were
hatchlings not yet big enough to ride
there were also 3 wild dragons living on
dragonstone
which had never been successfully
claimed by any rider
grey ghost sheep steeler and the
cannibal cyrex was rhaenyra targaryen's
dragon
her name came from a goddess of valyria
styrex had yellow scales
she was huge and formidable but not as
fierce some were experienced in battle
as daemon's characters
she was kept in chains and exceedingly
well-fed
cyrex was slain in the aftermath of the
storming of the dragon pit
prince geoffrey had attempted to mount
her to ride to the dragonpit
save the other dragons and perhaps mount
his own dragon tyraxes there
however dragons are not horses and they
will only accept one mount at a time
in mid-flight cyrex shrugged off joffrey
who fell to his death
cyrex eventually died fighting the
rioters on the ground
in 129 ac after the start of the dance
of the dragons
the second biggest dragon alive
vermeethar bent his neck to a
blacksmith's bastard called hugh hammer
during the second battle of tumbleton
adam valerian upon the dragon sea smoke
attacked vermithorn
sea smoke was a pale silver grey dragon
it was the fighting size during the
dance
but still a young dragon and nimbler in
the air than his older brothers
he was of comparable size to testrian
who was about three times smaller than
rumithar
and not as fierce i'm a beast as him in
comparison
just before this vermi 3's rider was
killed
vermithorn now riderless wounded and
enraged
took flight attacking all those around
him while vermythor was only 20 feet
above the field
sea smoke slammed into him from above
the two dragons strolled over the field
so entangled that neither was able to
break free
tasterian also entered the fight the
three dragons fought to the death
tasterian also known as the blow queen
was a she dragon
she was written by prince there on
targaryen the serion was a beautiful
blue she dragon
and her flames were cobalt blue in color
she was one of the smaller fighting
dragons
vermeethor killed sea smoke when he
locked his teeth into the ladder's neck
and ripped his head off
he attempted to take flight with his
prize still in his jaws
but his wings were tattered causing him
to be unable to bear the weight
after a moment he collapsed and died
tesserian was the last to die
on three occasions did she try to fly
again but
failed every time again by late
afternoon the day after the battle she
seemed to be in pain
at the command of lord benji cut
blackwood his best archer
shot three arrows into the dying
dragon's eye killing her
the fourth dragon silver ring was also
there but fled into the sky when the
battle began
however after the battle was over
silvering descended to land beside the
slain dragons
later the singers would tell of how she
tried to lift that vermithur's wing
three times with her nose as if to try
and make him fly again
silver wing was a silvery she dragon she
was ridden by queen ellis saint
targaryen
and by ulf white during the dance of the
dragons
silvering was the only one of only four
dragons still alive
at the end of the targaryen civil war
during this time of the dance of the
dragons fagar was the hardened survivor
of a hundred battles
had grown almost as large as valerian
and was the oldest and largest of the
dragon's investors
her roar was so powerful that it could
shake the very foundations of storm's
end
no living dragon could match her size or
ferocity
the color of vegard's scales horns wings
wing bones and spinal crest is unknown
as is the color of her flame prince
eamon was her dragon rider
at the beginning of the war regard
killed young dragon eriks
along with its dragon rider lucerus rax
was 5 times smaller than vagar
the storming of the dragonpit took place
during the riot of king's landing
during the dance of the dragons when the
rioters slew 4 dragons
shriekers young dragon unclaimed since
the death of prince joharis targaryen
morgil the dragon of princess jahira
targaryen
tyrex is the dragon ridden by prince
geoffrey valerian
and pale blue dragon dreamfire unclaimed
since queen healing a targaryen's death
unable to fly away as they had been
chained the four dragons fought with
their horns
claws and teeth they let loose their
dragonflame and transformed the
dragonpit into a fiery inferno
the first dragon to die was shrikhos who
was slain by hob
who leaped onto her neck and drove his
eggs down into the dragon's skull
next died morgul slained by the burning
knight who rushed into the dragon's
flame
and stabbed him repeatedly in the eye
with his spear as he burned to his own
death
tyrex's burndos who rushed at him from
his lair
until the front entrance of his lair was
completely blocked with corpses
however the mob broke through the back
door of the dragon's lair and slew him
last to die was dreamfire dreamfire was
the only drag unable to break free of
her chains when the mob broke in
she took wing circled the interior of
the dome
and swooped down to attack the man below
she slew more men than the other three
dragons combined
archers and crossbowmen loosed arrows
and quarrels at her
and whenever she landed men swarmed her
to attack
driving her back into the air eventually
one of her eyes was nicked by a crossbow
bolt
half blind and maddened dream fire flew
into the dragon pit's great dome above
which cracked on impact half of it came
tumbling down crushing her and the
dragon slayers
under tons of broken stone and rubble so
many dragons had died in the war
that the targaryens could not maintain a
stable breeding population
and few survivors became inbred and
sickly fortunately however
the key event of house of the dragon is
the exact same event which led to their
extinction
the targaryen civil war the dance of the
dragons
and we'll get to see them all on screen
part 2 of this video is coming tomorrow
when i will
cover even more dragons in fact some of
the most epic dragons and their fights
lots of dragons a lot of epic dragon
battles
all of that and more this game of
thrones prequel series house of the
dragons brings in 2022 on hbo
let me know your thoughts about
everything the prequel the mighty
dragons and their epic battles in the
comment section down below
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace